Game of Thrones has an extensive and
high quality Rogue Gallery I assume
everyone probably has their own favorite
villain in the series since there are so
many great options but for this video
I'm going to be making the case for why
Tywin is the best villain in the show
I'm going to cover five main topics that
all combine together in making Taiwan
the best and the first one is arguably
the most important in that Taiwan from
his perspective in the story is a good
guy now I feel like this is a topic that
comes up all the time that entices
actors towards playing villains and
that's within good reason because
villains that are essentially a good guy
but just have different motivations than
our main protagonists make more
compelling characters this definitely
doesn't downplay the joffreys and Ramses
within Game of Thrones because
unpredictability and true evil intent
can also be terrifying however Taiwan as
an overall character is more complex
because he isn't just causing chaos out
of enjoyment he's making logical
decisions that are deeply tied to what
motivates him so looking at Talon's
actions he surprisingly doesn't do much
bad things from his perspective truly
the only bad ax he did was setting the
riverlands on fire which is
understandable because it's wartime and
the Red Wedding but his reasoning for
doing so does make sense and he saved
lots of lives by ending the war albeit
he obviously did it in a bad way and he
also hates Tyrion but I wouldn't blame
him from how much he disgraces the
Lannister name so because Tywin isn't
going out of his way to cause harm and
just wants a stable realm that isn't in
constant rebellion and makes his
character more real and relatable we
establish a deeper connection with Tywin
because we understand his goal and it's
not compromised by constant heinousness
this allows the audience to build
sympathy and empathy for him and is
essentially why despite being a villain
there's a lovable aspect to him part of
that reason is Charles dances
performance which I'll get into later
but the writing for the character is
Pitch Perfect a father trying his best
to strengthen his family name is
constantly rectifying all the mistakes
made by his children and grandchildren
like the bad things he's done wouldn't
have been necessary had his family not
have made those issues so prevalent I
think a great set of scenes that helps
with sympathizing with Tywin and helps
the audience look past some of these bad
acts is his time with Arya them bonding
together brings out an aura of levity
for Tywin which is also ironic because
he never gets this feeling when
interacting with his own children and
quite the opposite in fact but with Arya
we peel back the curtain of taiwan's
strict and hard Persona of being a
commanding leader and we see a
thoughtful and caring man who
surprisingly is so interested in his cup
Bearer I feel like during the Showcase
if Taiwan was much more vile towards
Arya maybe she would have tried to
assassinate him even though the window
was very small to do so I feel like it
was partially ambiguous if Arya
hesitated since she kind of enjoyed her
time with Tywin she was visibly upset
when Talon left harrenhal without her
David and Dan actually do a great job
job here in humanizing Taiwan and these
scenes offer a lot of value because
nothing like these scenes happen later
in the show from here on out he's always
going to be a hard ass primarily because
going forward he'll be paired up with
his children all the time so his scenes
with Arya are that much more special
because we see a glimpse of the good
side of Tywin they deepened his
characteristics and thus make him a more
Rich villain that's why to me I have a
slight preference in this field for
Tywin in comparison to the other
villains of Game of Thrones he's not
just sympathetic but he's very complex
with Justified and relatable motivations
unlike any other villain Talon has a
unique set of traits that makes him very
strong and award the adversary within
the show he by far has the most
influence and power so this essentially
gives him free range to almost do
anything he wants and that makes him
scary to go up against as a byproduct
from this this also makes him very
ruthless intimidating and he's a very
intelligent strategist given his mass
amount of experience and age he is
probably the best player in Game of
Thrones he may not be as sleazy
maliciously backstabby as varus and
Littlefinger but their power completely
pales in comparison just seeing him walk
into a room and immediately seeing
everyone fold over themselves to try to
carry favor with him is a sight to
behold he constantly exudes big dick
energy and it's so much fun watching
Talon because of this power another
reason why it's so fun is the way he
overcomes conflict it's always done
through him dunking on people verbally
completely outsmarting them and just
holding so much authority over them that
they shatter into a million pieces the
only people that can sustain this crazy
beam of power that he unleashes when he
speaks are his kids but that's just
because he can't outright banish them to
the shadow realm anyone else though good
luck like him interacting with his
random Generals in season 2 was
hilarious any minor mistakes they made
they would immediately get drop kicked
by Tywin the times in which he is
actually matched in this cunning show of
power also makes for some incredible
moments I said it before in another
video but Olenna and Tywin sing together
where they talk about marrying their
kids is one of my favorite fight scenes
it perfectly highlights Talon's main
strength in that he's a manipulative
figure who's extremely intelligent and
can bends political mechanics to his
will threatening to draft in order to
make Loris Tyrell a member of the King's
Guard if he doesn't marry Cersei is such
a clever solution that is practically
uncounterable along with the
ramifications of this deal being massive
so just in one dialogue scene Talon
completely best Elena Tyrell and
strengthens his overall family position
this unique way of problem solving is
fresh in Game of Thrones because most
characters solve their problems through
combat this type of solution to conflict
is so much more intriguing because it
requires a wit and thus keeps you
engaged as a viewer without needing
action along with it offering two other
big factors like Variety in an already
Big Show and The unpredictability of how
Taiwan will best someone because when a
protagonist fights an antagonist in a
sword fight there are only so many
outcomes to that situation and the way
they carry out that goal is always the
same but outsmarting your opponent via
political means creates a more
interesting solution that is more fresh
and exciting another situation that I
love where town is mashed and even
bested was by Tyrion when he announces
he wants a trial by combat throughout
the show Talon gets his way and his
plans are always Immaculate and go
exactly as he wants Jaime discovers that
Tywin expected from the cave and to try
to make a bargain to save his brother in
which he'll take out the
responsibilities of his house so as an
audience we assume that yet again Taiwan
has won in an intelligent way but Tyrion
has one final Uno reverse card and the
star down they give each other at the
end of the episode is truly iconic it
visually shows that they are true Rivals
and Tyrion given how smart he is can
really challenge his father plus his
added immunity of being his son allows
for this intellectual bad model to be
more engaging since Talent can outright
get rid of him that's why their scenes
together are definitely my favorite in
the show and I'll go into more detail
about them in a bit but briefly going
into the ending of Talon's character
it's a plain and simple Masterpiece from
a writing standpoint it's a perfect
ironic event given the character at hand
and the fact that it's carried out by
Tyrion explodes the scene with so much
emotion and release of tension so much
build up for Tyrion has led up to this
moment and it makes it a Monumental
death scene despite it happening in the
[__] I really can't imagine a better
place for this type of villain to die
but yeah as a villain Talon's
characteristics and the way he overcomes
conflict with them makes him so engaging
and given those characteristics the way
he dies is outstanding a part of how we
quantify a villain's worth is how much
they impact the plots and our main
characters if you look at any great
villain they'll generally check off both
of these boxes in a big way a couple
examples for the character aspect
include Ramsay torturing and thoroughly
changing the genetic makeup of Theon and
Joffrey tormenting Sansa while also
making Tyrion go crazy with his terrible
decisions Taiwan has a major hold over
Tyrion Cersei and Jaime so literally all
of his scenes are so complex and
interesting because there is a rich
Dynamic playing out in all of them
between him and his children like try to
think about it almost all of his most
memorable scenes revolve around him
interacting with his children he's
deeply attached to them and they affect
him just as much as he affects them
there are a constant stain on his legacy
and is more of a conflict to him than
really anything else which is kind of
funny given that he's actively fighting
a war for three seasons now you may be
thinking that Rob is Talon's primary
antagonist but that is half true on a
plot basis Rob is Talon's antagonist
however on a character basis his
children are taoan values his family
name above all else so his biggest
obstacle is wrangling his children
Tyrion is a constant disappointment and
an embarrassment to the land Lannister
name Cersei is tired of being
disrespected and no longer wants to do
what she's told and Jaime refuses to
progress the family name with handsome
children imagine wasting those god-like
jeans holy [__] so because Talon affects
multiple main characters drastically and
makes him extremely important within the
story he sends them down massive
character arcs and is the main obstacle
for all of them and in overcoming him
they evolve as characters like Cersei
standing up to Tyron and threatening to
go public with the vile news of incest
releasing her from his grip and giving
her Freedom Tyrion killing his father
and finally escaping the emotional
turmoil and manipulation and staring him
his entire life and Jaime finally being
able to live a life of his choosing
without his father breathing down his
neck so in terms of all of the villains
town has the largest reach in terms of
character impact because villains are
generally more focused and will
specialize with challenging one
character but Tywin he juggles three
successfully while also dealing with
other k characters briefly a part of why
some villains may come across as doll
like euron Greyjoy is that they don't
challenge anyone on a character level
there's no deep insights the characters
have to evaluate about themselves and
overcoming him so they never change as
characters from said conflict he's just
there to carry out certain plot points
and to supply a superficial obstacle for
the good guys to overcome to be fair
though some villains physically just
can't accomplish this since it wouldn't
make sense within the story to have the
villain and protagonists regularly have
scenes together that's why I think some
villains like Cersei became shallower in
season 8 because they didn't have any
protagonists to interact with the first
four seasons because of this was just
writing Brilliance in which he had a
perfect mixture of protagonist and
antagonists in a single space it was a
constant hurricane of conflict and Tywin
was in the eye of the storm to me that
was the embodiment of what made Game of
Thrones so amazing and talwin's effect
on everyone within King's Landing
increased the depth significantly going
in into the other half of the statement
where a villain has to heavily impact
the plot and main characters let's look
at how much Taiwan affects the story
from an overall perspective Tower is a
very busy guy he's strategizing and
leading a war he's doing all of
Joffrey's work he's setting up crucial
alliances and pairing up marriages and
he's always working behind the scenes
like screwing over Rob Stark with the
right wedding even though he doesn't go
up against Rob Stark he's actively
challenging him off screen it definitely
would have been cool to see more of his
battles with Rob Stark and him planning
out different strategies but
unfortunately a lot of the battles
during the war of the five Kings Arc
were cut for budgets nonetheless though
Taiwan was still heavily involved and
this made him a very important figure
early on in the show the fact that
through the course of his screen time
that he essentially opposes almost every
character is impressive from her writing
standpoint it's like Ip Man fighting 10
black belts at once but on a macro scale
normally villains will just have a
direct tie to one subject at a time
which will thus to increase the
connection between them given that you
aren't splitting time between a bunch of
things Taiwan on the other hand
simultaneously affects so much but he
never feels overextended the writers
expertly utilize town where it matters
most and a lot of that time is with his
kids his macro problems don't require
many scenes or could also be done
efficiently like discussing the war and
then transitioning into a more personal
moment with his children like in season
one it creates a great sense of
efficiency with the character and how
they influence different parts of the
show and it never feels like Taiwan is
being underutilized like a really smart
example of efficiency is Talent carrying
out his work of hand of the king where
he's writing a letter but he's doing so
while Cersei is visiting so this creates
a statement that Talon cares more about
writing a letter than his own daughter
it's extremely disrespectful and it
knocks out two birds with one stone
along with it returning later on in the
show where Cersei does the same tactic
against Elena Tyrell the fact that Talon
affects so much of the show I think
increases his value you as a villain it
makes it more significant since anything
and everything he does carries so much
weight and causes ripples throughout the
entire world of Westeros the larger the
impact they have the better and Taiwan
created a massive tsunami with the right
wedding really the only other villain
that comes close in this regard is
Joffrey killing Ned Stark and that
completely shattered the realm and the
Red Wedding did the same however I think
Talon consistently keeps his pressure on
the whole world more than Joffrey does
lastly and certainly not least let's
finally look at the performance of
Charles Dance AS Tyron Lannister this is
the definition of an iconic and
memorable performance it requires a lot
of subtlety gravitas and intimidation
through sheer confidence he is not a
character who has a lot of emotional
outbursts so you have to communicate a
lot with subtle acting the true gems of
his performance are the Minor Details
that allude to certain things that he
doesn't want to say or wants to suppress
the best example of this is his talks
with Tyrion where you can can see the
pure hatred in his eyes there's so much
subtext and under the surface mind games
and their dialogue scenes and this also
alludes a lot to their backstory as well
it's so much fun picking up on all the
small details from these actors and it
makes watching them riveting like
Charles Dance can be extremely
expressive with his eyes and eyebrows he
can go from one end of the spectrum
where he's giving someone the death
glare that makes them melt to something
that can be more lively I really love it
whenever you Squints at Tyrion and he
can just tell how pissed off he is
Charles Dance also Paces character beats
really slow and allows them to build for
dramatic suspense he kinda turns it into
a power play as the opposing character
awaits in fear about what he's going to
say it allows his piercing glare to sink
in longer and get under their skin thus
breaking them down a good example of
this is whenever he puts Joffrey in his
place he slowly tears into his soul with
his death glare and then rips out his
heart when he finally delivers his
gut-wrenching line this I think elevates
the menacing factor of Taiwan and makes
him an even stronger villain the slower
Pace delivery also gives him an air of
higher class which upgrades his badass
degree he's never groveling or breaking
up to reduce his strong overall
composure and very very rarely does he
ever show his emotions I think only once
in the show does he actually break down
and that's when he admits his true
disdain towards Tyrion the moment he
really releases floors you because in
every scene leading up to this he's been
very serious and closed off to me it's
just very cathartic to see a hardened
character finally open up and Charles
Dance an outstanding job in the scene
out of all of them it's probably my
favorite another classic aspect about
the character is obviously his
commanding voice it carries a deep
confident tone that demands attention
and respect when he speaks his voice is
always measured and deliberates
reflecting his calculated and
intelligent nature it's the literal
embodiment of the character's power and
he Wills his authoritative deep voice as
if it's a sword he cuts through every
surrounding character with it you can't
help but love his voice and I think it's
the primary reason why he's a fan
favorite character I can listen to his
smooth voice for hours and Charles Dance
was really blessed by the genetic
Lottery but still though the way he
utilizes his voice in the show excels
town when Lannister into an iconic
status his overall acting is amazing and
perfectly suits the character at hand
easily one of and if not the best
casting choice in the show so yeah those
five reasons are why he's my favorite
villain in Game of Thrones and honestly
Joffrey I think is a very close second
since he also applies strongly to a lot
of these categories or even other
villains like Cersei and Ramsey the fact
that we have this many great villains is
incredible and is a part of why Game of
Thrones is one of the best shows
I quickly want to announce a few big
things to this channel firstly I started
a patreon since my channel is currently
demonetized so if you want to support me
at all that would be insanely generous
and you'll get rewards in return I also
started a Discord server for the channel
where I can get to know you guys more
and discuss things like movies and shows
and in general grow this community then
lastly I'll try to start streaming once
weekly I'll actually be streaming right
now as this video is live if you're here
within the first few hours and I'll be
using a face cam so if you're curious
what I look like then come in and drop a
follow and we can talk about whatever
you want links to all of these will be
in the description and thank you in
advance if you choose to engage further
with the channel
thank you
foreign